time for our scene and unseen segment we
expose the cultural stories of the day
and for that we turn to fox news
contributor raymond arroyo all right
raymond um the president is in israel
tonight
yeah but laura the change of location
has not helped the primary difficulty
here
this is the president asking where do i
go just before he left for israel
yesterday and after landing in tel aviv
he still didn't know where he was
supposed to go
later today
i will once more return to the hollow
ground of yad vashem
to keep alive the truth and honor of the
holocaust horror of the holocaust
and so i hope that we so pay attention
to one another
laura at least we can be thankful he
didn't compare the israelis to matzo
ball soup or falafel so this is a big
improvement over recent days but they
move him around like a wax work at
madame tussauds
while the international alliance
collapses in the middle east falls to
pieces meanwhile putin is about to meet
with iran
just as joe leaves the middle east good
luck to that foreign policy
is this a staffing problem i mean are
they not telling him where he's supposed
to go or does he forget or it is a long
trip and maybe he's just a little tired
maybe he only can work a few hours a day
so let's hope so all right and back home
raymond kamala was
taking care of the major issues facing
the country i understand
and it's tonight's harris rerun rerun
rerun together we are expanding access
to transportation
seems like maybe it's a small issue it's
a big issue you need to get to go and
need to be able to get where you need to
go to do the work and get home
this could turn out to be one of the
great american drinking games games
where people drink in america every time
she repeats something
the drinking games could happen in
america in america i'm looking forward
to that we should start that here well
she's struggling there raymond now let's
move on to the nominees for tv's highest
honors which were just announced i
understand what do they tell us
well for starters the most watched
scripted drama on television yellowstone
got no nominations of course nothing
laura but you'll be happy to know lizzo
got a nod for best competition show it's
called lizzo's watch out for the big
girls i'm not sure what this plus size
competition is since i've never watched
it but it it might have something to do
with who has the most resilient lycra uh
i will update you on that uh but
they're having a lot of fun they're
having a lot of fun there on that show
it looks like well um yellowstone of
course they stiff-armed yellowstone the
best show the absolute best show and as
like conservative kind of general sort
of sentiment uh old west they hate the
old west all right dave chappelle also
got a nod raymond for his closer comedy
special which is pretty remarkable given
all his controversies
well what's really remarkable or is a
nominee for outstanding narrator it went
to the new jack hannah the david
attenborough of our generation because
when you think nature this is the only
man you think of
this sloth has an entire micro kingdom
living in his fur wild spaces are where
we can connect with ourselves our
families and something greater than us
[Music]
they may have well called this category
laura outstanding narration by someone
elected president from 2009 to 2017. i
mean come on you know who's gonna win
this one
oh my god didn't he won the m
didn't he already win an emmy an oscar
did he win like every award
of course the nobel peace prize for
being in office for five minutes
remember that so he won pretty much
everything all right what else he's he
got in yeah he's got just about
everything and the nobel uh finally
there's a new trend of turning to
medical procedures to protest the
supreme court's abortion decision and
not only women are doing it
more men are taking action themselves in
the aftermath of roe v wade turning to
vasectomies i've always thought about
this decision
the supreme court did push me to finally
do it for figueroa this is also about
easing the burden on women who have had
their constitutional right to abortion
taken away i feel for a lot of men
especially for myself that this is a way
where they're trying to protect their
girlfriends they're trying to protect
their partners
oh please he's protecting himself give
me a break how do you like sterility as
protest and that's what we're seeing
here laura the most disturbing thing
women apparently according to newsweek
last week the google searches for female
sterility was through the roof
sterilization of females so this is
really and what you saw here is the
media it's a propaganda push for
sterility rather than motherhood
fatherhood
love together to build a family or
taking care of mothers in need that's
what we should be showing through the
media not pushing people to stop their
reproduction and not all these
vasectomies by the way can be reversed
just word to the wise fellas
i hate to cut this segment short on the
um
the second people there
raymond first of all he looks like
what's the what's the senator's name
from um georgia the young the young guy
ossoff he looks like ossoff yes he does
that kid he looks like a pajama boy
meets ossoff that was a
i'm not sure about what got in his mind
but he's going to regret that decision
raymond you have to worry about you know
anyway very good we got we got to cut
this all right raymond thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else